foreign
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to the
lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout here from sunny san francisco
california i'm mike mccarty your host
here with rob hanlery hi how are you
good uh pete brown's out today he's not
he's got a lot going on but you've been
on the lobby a lot before i have i'm
your second tier so you're gonna be
that's fine
the b squad no not at all it's always a
pleasure to have you on uh you were just
talking about titanfall 2 again you said
i mean
every time you've come on the lobby you
somehow bring up titanfall 2. it's just
so good
i have to cut you off before you talk
forever about titanfall 2. that's fine
it'll happen uh cool and then joey
what's up i'm d squad here
d scott what is this like uh
second third time in the lobby it's my
second cool and uh we're bringing you on
because you played a lot of fighting
games and you've been playing injustice
too we're gonna get into that but uh
what have you been playing lately
anything been playing lately or just
beat resident evil 7. nice we'll talk
about that too uh we're gonna save that
but um we do have a couple things to get
through uh obviously i want to do my
newsreel just smaller news stories but
first
we have another giveaway we're on like a
hot streak lately we have a bunch uh
this one speaking of resume seven
oh my god rob handler you show this off
oh my god uh other side maybe better so
we have resident evil 7 collector's
edition so let me preface this by saying
it does not
originally come with a game in it um so
there's like a there's the mansion music
box that plays part of the theme um
dummy finger usb drive of old vhs tape
um
i guess but we do we did put an xbox one
copy of the game in here so if you want
this uh gamespot will be tweeting like
pretty much right now i think in a few
minutes uh
respond to that tweet about the giveaway
and
we'll about pick you later in the week
and uh obviously if you have an xbox one
this is ideal for you because it has an
xbox one copy that we've put in it
awesome
it's pretty crazy to think like how old
vhs
tapes and
players are now yeah you know what i
mean like
do you does anyone have one
yes
you do yeah this game collects romantic
he collects romantic comedies we're
talking about that here what yeah we are
my parents house i have them but yeah
how big is your romantic comedy
collection so far
it's not that big
okay but
relatively compared to other creeps who
no i'm just kidding sorry that was that
was harsh uh wait how about how many do
you have i wouldn't say
maybe 12 right now oh okay i thought
you're gonna say like 50. oh god i'm
just kidding i will get there yeah
there's a copy of what women want on his
desk
on vhs and he watched it i was using the
vhs or the vcr that capcom sent us yeah
just to clarify as always we have the
chat here pretty much right in front of
us so if you're on youtube or twitch we
can see everything you're saying
uh and uh yeah feel free to join the
conversation all we have a lot of
questions for all of our segments uh
shiva and our social team tweet it out
uh you know if you want to send
questions to lobby like earlier this
week so we have a lot of good questions
but feel free to add the chat we will be
checking that out
all right some quick smaller news items
i want to get through before we get into
the main segments um
first of all bioware
said like their new ip is uh on the way
like going to be announced soonish um
obviously mass effect andromeda is
coming on march
21st is it 24th 21st uh and this one's
separate but apparently it's been in
development for five years andrew wilson
on an ea call said it will have new
universe new characters new story lines
and according to
andrew wilson again it will bring
players together in exciting new ways
but you know that sounds kind of like
you know buzzwords but i don't know they
keep stressing that there are other
quotes that were suggesting there might
be like more like different you know
social aspects to it so who knows we're
gonna talk more about that what we might
want from bioware but i think we've kind
of done stuff like that before we're
gonna wait until more news comes out
before we dive into that um for honor
open beta was announced so we uh
gamespot and a few you know like other
outlets and stuff we're playing the 400
closed beta recently i know spencer was
getting into it uh ben jank on our
social or on our
video publishing team was kind of
playing a lot of it um we have a lot of
footage so you should go check out that
footage on our site if you get the
chance but february 9th to 12th the game
will be in open beta if you want to sign
up for that on all platforms so you
could play that before it comes out two
days after on valentine's day
if you're one of those people
um there will be four modes in the open
beta and nine heroes so if you wanna
check that out before the game comes out
those are the dates um for you sports
fans uh as is tradition every year met
in nfl 17 they ran the simulation to see
who would win the super bowl who do you
guys think did you what did you see i
have no idea i don't even know who's
playing right now patriots patriots okay
so it's a patriot new england patriots
in the atlanta falcons and yeah patriots
come behind the last second to win 27-24
not a wide margin but i think if you're
not a patriots fan everybody wants a
patriot they're like
i'm not much of a football uh fan but i
was just hearing i think someone talk
about how like
it really just comes out you look like
last year right with the panthers uh
what's his name the quarterback for the
panthers cam newton cam newton like
really great but it was just all about
how you know we got someone like tom
brady who's been to the super bowl so
many times is so comfortable and it's
those
nervous shakes you gotta like get rid of
uh
and that's why i feel like it's just
gonna go right to the patriots but
i don't know anything else new york
giants are not in super bowl so i don't
care um star wars battlefront 2 for last
news item is confirmed now after strong
hinting that it will have a campaign
story campaign which people uh you know
did not have it in the first battlefront
last year
um and i did not like
two years ago battlefront was two years
ago now done 15. damn that was a while
i did not like it that much it was a
good game it was kind of boring but
hopefully maybe a single player campaign
will lend it some longevity it also
according to andrew wilson i think this
was the same call when he was talking
about bioware's new ip um battlefront 2
will span multiple eras uh he didn't
mention rogue one and the force awakens
but we were thinking maybe it'll be do
you think there'll be clone wars stuff i
hope so man that was like so awesome in
uh battlefront 2 was it in battlefield 1
did they have yes but it was
more expanded and everything into i mean
you just got so much
uh
opportunity to use this diversity of uh
you know i think what it really comes
down to is like
you you'll go look at something like
battlefront the most recent one where
it's just
walkers like the imperial imperial army
is so overpowered right like there's not
a lot of landing craft or like uh land
vehicles for the rebels
here you have like just like such even
like plates like all around um with like
the clone and the um
uh you know the droid army uh trade
federation but uh i just want to be a
destroyer droid again roll around did
you play republic commando no i did not
no did you no that i like that game i
think it's pretty
jean-luc uh from the back room on our
track hastert has piped in saying
republic commando is the best star wars
game i don't know if i know about think
of that but it's a really good game if
you're into tactical shooters
it's
it's kind of uh
it's a like a vanilla tactical shooter
it's not like rainbow six level of depth
but it's good i like it a lot all right
now moving on to our first segment
we're going to talk about injustice 2. i
thought it was injustice gods among us
too but it's just injustice yeah they
dropped the uh the subtitle yeah which
is probably good it's got more of a ring
to it did you play you played a decent
amount of the beta i played a little bit
i think eric tay uh played a lot more
than me because he also streamed it all
right um
were you a fan of first one
actually no i wasn't
um as far as fighting games go i'm more
[Music]
i'm more of a marvel player which is a
completely different style than
injustice um
netherrealm studios usually has like a
very very specific feel to their games
which is not i'm not supe like i'm not a
super fan of it but i like to see like
what they do with the characters um if
you remember in mortal kombat and then i
think and also the first injustice they
did a lot of cross
uh like third-party characters
put into their games like there was a
there was predator there was jason
voorhees yeah jason voorhees leatherface
alien from alien yeah morph leatherface
was the weirdest one i mean texas
chainsaw mascara isn't like an obscure
horror movie but i wouldn't put
leatherface in a fighting game arena but
worked out i guess yeah he's not he's
not as like high profiles like freddy
krueger or something like that right um
so
we wanted to talk about kind of your
time with the beta briefly before we get
into what dlc characters we might want
to see whether they be obscure dc
characters or
we kind of just went crazy with who we
want to see not just in this game but in
a fighting game because you know like
once they open the door with michael or
sorry with jason voorhees and uh you
know predator and alien it kind of
made us think who else would we want to
see in this game but first you said like
it it's got a feel obviously like mortal
kombats another realm studios um this
will be their biggest roster ever right
now it looks like there's 28 characters
right um based on the open beta you
could play how many like six you could
play four four and then there were like
28 slots though on the characters yeah
so right now there's batman superman
there's also a super girl
and atrocitus okay i'm not sure where
it's from
no um but they've also revealed uh they
revealed robin
last week uh they've also shown off uh
footage from i think was aquaman
uh who else was there i think poison ivy
yeah it'll be it was a couple other ones
poison ivy aquaman atrocitus you
mentioned
um yeah i'll look that up but but how
does it feel so far like uh this game is
how far from release
we are about three months away i think
how does it feel right now it feels
pretty good like uh i didn't play a lot
of the first injustice but from what i
have played of the second one it feels
mechanically the game feels the same um
there's a lot
probably a lot more moves that like i
don't even know about right now
um
but if you can see right here like the
stages look like the presentation of the
game is actually pretty spectacular sure
um that was always my favorite part
about uh gods among us just like is like
the crazy moves like superman would
bring someone to orbit and then throw
them back at the earth yeah that's what
they do here too yeah like i don't play
many fighting games but
you know mortal kombat like netherrealm
games are the ones i play i don't play
much street fighter or you know like
marvel vs capcom which i know people are
excited about the next one coming out
for that yeah you're more of a street
fighter fan yeah okay but right now uh
this is you know it's promising
it looks it looks really fun to play
like
more than anything else at least for me
is the spectacle of the game much like
you know something
like batman vs superman the the movie it
was it was all about like you know these
moments and like the big shots that you
know or that you can hang on a wall or
something like that that this game will
have that cool um
who did you say you have like a favorite
character based on the beta
so far um not right now i mean they've
the playable beta only has four and two
of them were already in the previous
game not a huge pool to pick from no not
yet okay so let's get into the fun part
we uh kind of yesterday when we were
talking about segments one during the
lobby i was trying to figure out how
best to uh pursue this one because there
were a lot of fans of uh you know
netherrealms this game out there or at
least like a lot of people anticipating
it um i wanted to ask you guys who you
think would be good dlc characters i'm
basing this off a conversation joey you
pointed me toward
ed boone and people at netherrealm um
had a live stream uh kind of showing off
the beta and they were talking about
like future dlc and whatnot and ed boone
said they would be going into unique
characters that are more dec more
obscure in the dc universe so i picked
up a few of those to talk about but he
also said that they'd be surprised if
they did not have third-party characters
pop-up as dlc yes so we're talking about
like you said kind of uh leather face
from
texas chainsaw massacre or
the xenomorph from alien or predator
from predator uh so we kind of went
crazy at least i did with uh other
people we might want to see in these
games but first let's stick to dc um
i literally just pulled up a list i
don't know dc all that well outside of
the main one
like main characters i'm not like super
into comics but obviously like they're
not gonna have captain america in this
game because they won't have marvel but
then i looked up people like captain
adam uh oh do you know no i'm curious no
like the name adam yeah he's in 196 no
adam like atom he's a 1960s air force
officer nathaniel adam spelled the name
way he took part in an experiment to
test the durability of a crashed alien
ship spaceship he kind of looks like dr
manhattan from uh watchmen right um the
explosion resulted that needing a nuke
on the spaceship
hurled captain adam into modern times
with the alien metal bonded to his body
and granting him the superpower to
control energy kind of
sounds like dr manhattan i don't even
know that's like some magneto power you
know what i mean like that's
pretty broad yes energy
is mine uh there's another guy called uh
major bummer
the slacker 90s lives on
in lou martin he was your typical young
slacker who was accidentally endowed
with superpowers from some dim-witted
alien college students
now a reluctant superhero major bomber
stumbles through life fighting crime
only when he has to and slowly learned
about the whole great responsibility
motif in a roundabout way i'm reading
this on uh screenrant.com because i
don't i don't know any of these people
enemy ace oh you rob you'll like this
one he's loosely based on the red baron
oh yeah he's uh
his hans von hammer
a german world war one fighter pilot who
was a classic anti-hero
uh so he was german from world war one
character it's interesting i have you on
my sides
keep going keep going 12 o'clock hi
keep going no i'm not come on um
so apparently he's just a pilot he
doesn't have superpowers that'd be fun
what if he was just in a plane the whole
time
come down
let's fly
he just does strafing runs on batman
uh and then i see people like warlord
the demon this probably means more to
people who know all these characters but
if i don't know they seem super obscure
let's get into the ones we wanted to see
in terms of third party characters i
have actually a question about aquaman
what does aquaman like
out of water
like a fish is he a human i think like
what's what's his power out of water
can you control like the faucet like
i'm just he's in the game right is that
that's why i heard i mean what does does
he have any like cool powers
nah i think he just can control water
shoot water people fish
some like maybe like amphibians can
throw a shark at him i think i don't
know
it'd be cool if he like brought
like as a finish or brought someone back
into the ocean yeah uh jason gusher
jason gusher on our youtube chat says
does bob ross join the injustice league
and make happy little accidents
uh yeah people are talking about bob
ross in the chat right now i'm not sure
how it came up but bob ross would be a
pretty sick character to have an
injustice 2.
yeah that'd be pretty cool
we're already getting here
no not yet uh joey you had a few ideas
for okay well while we're getting the
bar characters i have a couple of ideas
for characters but while we're on the
topic of at least superheroes have you
guys seen the movie mystery man no yes
yes that's a really good movie yeah and
that's like i think it's dark horse
comics but
just as far as superheroes go those guys
are like
not heroes at all but they just have
like these powers that they kind of made
up for themselves there's a guy who's
like really good
um at wheeling a shovel played by like
william h macy yeah ben stiller is like
a guy who just gets really really angry
oh [ __ ]
no this is really good movie uh it i
think it almost came out prior to like
all those marvel movies it was it was
going to be nine yeah so it's pretty
interesting how oh yeah yeah it is so
like they're up on screen it is really
underrated um
what's his name uh from the simpsons uh
knives he throws forks and spoons
there's also here we go sorry quickly
backtrack absolute configuration or
youtube chat aquaman can control tides
is an expert fighter with his trident
and can command fish cool so you go
through that thank you uh there's also
uh
uh uh dane cook is in it before he like
yeah he's in one quick moment and
they're doing tryouts and there's a
scene where he he he's i'm waffle man
he's kind of golden crispy bad guys are
history yeah and he burns himself it's
really weird
so this is it is a comedy yes yes all
right i'll check it out do you recommend
it yes does it hold up when's the last
time you watched it uh probably a couple
years ago but i think like it has a
goofy sense of humor that it's like it's
well encapsulated yeah it doesn't like
age that much i don't think is the is
the song all-star yes
philanthropy is saying this is the movie
they wrote it for
i don't know if they wrote it for this
shrek or rat race all three of which
were like rat race and track i've seen
all three of those like to find my
childhood but that's okay but anyway
yeah cool so all right let's talk about
it
okay so what are some characters you
said you want to see uh first one that i
thought of um who i think is who might
be perfect for this is neo from the
matrix yeah and i say that for a couple
reasons one he's pretty much already a
superhero he can fly he can teleport or
whatever else he can do pretty much
everything
but also because he is warner brothers
property
and he would fit i think he would fit
very well in this game i could totally
see it like visually right him just like
hover moves like flying around like you
know just like the last movie the third
one like just that agent smith battle
with him it was basically a fighting
game it was like dragon ball i think
yeah the flying in the air
all right there's neil right there
that's the best footage we had in neo
apparently uh legit what are some other
ideas you had um another one i was just
going along like the the warner brothers
property line seeing what works
what do you think about mad max
oh i i had mentioned that too yeah from
next and then or or furiosa either one
of them
i think that would be furious or i would
rather see furiosa but mad max would be
awesome too just because like the game
what it was like two years ago 2015 yeah
it was kind of an underwhelming game but
that would have been like
just thinking of furiosa's robot arm
that she uses robot arm and her
like super can be like driving her truck
or something like that fatality what
would like what would
mad max's fatality even be
[Music]
being quiet probably not saying anything
and shooting a gun dare down what is tay
saying
tastes telling us
there's no fake oh it's not a fatality
sorry superman oh my god i'm getting my
nether realm stuff mixed up all right
joey any other ideas
uh i also wrote down king leonidas from
300
oh yeah that's another wonder brothers
property but he also has an entire army
with them so they can join in and help
all right rob
[Music]
well i just realized that this is the
same actor but constantine
just just you just want keanu reeves
i forgot i was the same guy
john wick and also i have the guy from
speed right
uh
i was going through just movies like
from the 90s
i just watched john wick last night jake
decker is in the twitch chat talking
about it that's another one that you
could use
she should just be keanu reeves keanu
reeves and it's just those like
characters and his super moves tay will
be just uh right
and then staring at you another one i
had i realized it's probably not
not perfect as far as scale but like we
mentioned iron giant
giant i mean come on the end of the
movie he is op
with those like weapons yeah so all
right i went along a couple lines uh
some serious some not so serious okay
all right first off just the fact that
jason voorhees was uh and leatherface
were in
combat 10. i just would love to see
michael myers or freddy krueger
but like reprising the role reprising
the role yes uh just like
in general just i think freddie cougar
would be the best of those two like the
needle thing like the with the the
knives he's got he's got all those like
weird uh you know dream sequences that
the super move would be pretty sweet
like putting someone to sleep or waiting
till they fall asleep he just hides
until they fall asleep and then enters
them and kills him uh and then i'll
think along like action movie things
like since the xenomorph is in there
from alien and predator from aptly named
predator i was thinking t-1000
oh my god terminator oh my god not
arnold schwarzenegger but like
determinator t-1000 is like ultimate
yeah villain dude that'd be pretty sweet
oh my god he's got so many moves that
would be awesome um
and of course
so i took the liberty of looking back
through to end this segment and before
we get to a couple questions i took the
liberty of getting
back through the warner bros catalog of
video games and there is a ps2 game that
i want jean-luc to throw up right now i
think
would have a pretty sick cast for uh
injustice 2. okay yeah let's see if
jean-luc can throw it up or when he gets
the chance
okay um
also
t1000 super could be like have you seen
this boy
that'll be pretty unreal he stabs him
through the knife all right here we go
guys
ps2 title yeah
friends the ones with all the trivia
warner bros worked on i'm talking
chandler i'm talking rachel i'm talking
phoebe
we're getting all six in tin justice two
guys dancing rachel with her with her
fashion sensibilities ross with his
intelligence
monica with her no-nonsense attitude in
her cooking abilities phoebe raised on
the mean streets in new york uh joey he
loves pizza you know he does and
chandler sassy and sarcastic and equal
measures we're getting the entire cast
of friends and injustice too netherrealm
you can thank me when you get the chance
uh i'm looking forward to seeing some
sick super moves rob i can see you're
super happy about this
yeah
what are you thinking
i'm thinking that this is possibly one
of the best segments i've ever
seen in my life
all right there we go wow sick the one
with all the trivia you go press the
start button yeah all right there we go
i got that
what so for all you friends fans out
there all right cool so i'm going to get
to some questions quick from um
people on twitter who responded to game
spots like
questions we got off the rails really
easy and really early in this one joey
did you get to see uh mike and hike on
twitter was asking about the gear in
injustice 2 which seems to be part of
the longevity yeah did you get to see
much of that i got i got to see a little
bit of it and that's kind of strange for
a fighting game where pretty much after
every like competitive match that you
play a piece of gear will drop and
you'll be able to equip it it's pretty
constant trickle yeah so you'll be able
to upgrade like your stats like as you
as you play online and i i'm not sure
but i think it also like changes the the
physical appearance of your character as
well okay so like as people get stronger
you'll be able to actually visibly see
their progress which i think is actually
pretty cool cool cool um and then so
that's just kind of
was that across all modes you're getting
gaining gear do you know i believe it's
just uh like competitive online modes
okay cool um
so in general so someone's asking uh
drew mccutcheon on
uh twitch had asked if there's gonna be
a season pass i'm assuming there will be
i don't know if oh with all the dlc
characters right for a fighting game
that's kind of easy um
cool and then how big will the injustice
2 roster will be darren wright was
asking any characters not returning from
one i believe there are a few characters
that won't be in it not exactly sure
they haven't released the full cast yet
but they like ed boone has said that it
will be the largest roster of any nether
home game that
has ever been made okay yeah because
right now there's 28 there will be 28 to
start but we only have plenty they'll
probably be like tons of dlc characters
cool awesome so that was our very
serious segment about injustice 2. uh so
if you do have questions any further
questions feel free to uh
leave your thoughts in our comments on
youtube or on gamespot and we will do
our best to respond them
cool
all right joey thanks for coming on
appreciate it i'm going to bring kelly
plaggy on for the rest of the show
um we are getting into i see a lot of
people asking about horizon we're
getting into that later kelly went to a
preview event in la about a week ago
so uh we're gonna bring her on
rob are you friends fan
no so you hated that
yeah that was funny
sally what's up hi kelly's been at
gamespot for about like a month now a
little not even not a month no yeah a
month now just kidding okay
and uh your associate editor here you
have been kind of busy right away i've
been in the lobby your first week i
think second week second week who knows
yeah so we're going to talk about
residual seven i know you're like a
horror fan as well so you're here for a
few segments did you get the player
around seven yet yeah a little bit i
haven't finished it yet because i was
home alone all week
weekend and i live in the basement of my
house oh and so i was like i don't
really wanna
die this weekend that sounds like
like ideal conditions oh man oh
i really thought i was going to have
freak out if i tried to go in that's
first thing so what else you've been
playing lately yeah i uh just reviewed
poochie and yoshi's woolly world totally
just a hard right on that one is that
published yes sweet so people can check
that out on gamespot yeah you can check
that out on gamespot.com okay perfectly
website you might have heard of and um
uh i still play pokemon moon
cause i'm one of those people so that's
what i've been up to awesome so we're
going to jump right into resident evil 7
uh we will get to horizon zero dawn
later in the show for those asking um
to backtrack really quick uh dk on the
youtube chat said pete brown is the ross
of game spot he's tough but fair with a
keen eye for detail
if you're in the chat please let this
keep coming in if you know people on
gamespot and you know friends i'd love
to get some more comparison someone tell
me who rob is on friends because he's
i'm sure he loves this
all right
keller are you a friends fan oh yeah
i've been waiting to get friends on the
lobby since i started at gamespot that
was almost two years that was the
highlight of my morning watching that go
down okay perfect
ed boone's gonna be thanking me in like
a few months okay cool let's jump right
in so resident evil 7 uh the banned
footage dlc is out how many days after
release
one week yeah um and i know
it's actually
it is crazy how fast it was because i
don't even like i know a lot of people
haven't finished the game yet like you
were saying you need to finish it still
right yeah
yeah
same with you and we i beat it
a while ago a couple days before
it released and uh i liked it a lot i
want to replay it in
mad house mode jean-luc's been doing
that he's playing in vr which is crazy
to me he played through the entire game
in vr but um
which apparently you can for this
for this game uh it's really vr is great
in this game but
we uh
i played the band footage so if you guys
had questions i feel like uh yeah we got
a lot of questions through uh twitch if
you uh or sorry twitter if you're on
twitch or youtube and have questions
feel free to hurl them my way uh so just
to preface it quick nightmare is one of
the tapes that's essentially like a
survival run in the basement um from
what i played you can unlock a harder
difficulty but you essentially just run
around the basement trying to survive
like five waves of molded and crawlers
and uh i don't want to spoil too much
but there are other kind of like mini
bosses involved
but you're collecting you're finding
these compactors that you turn on for
scrap and how it works is you're kind of
trying to unlock more of the basement so
you can loop around but to do that you
need to buy like these corrosive things
to melt these locks and then you uh you
know you just kind of say do i want to
buy a handgun or do i want to upgrade my
health or do i want to buy the m37
shotgun or flame rounds
or of course you know first aid
but you're also kind of trying to find
these compactors they like slowly deal
out
increments of 100 scrap which you're
using to buy these as you can see here
but you are
essentially just trying to
you're surviving right but it's at a
certain point the compactors will stop
giving you scrap so then you just kind
of have to fight with what you've got i
got to the last [ __ ] enemy on wave
five and died this is a compactor right
here you can if you're watching this uh
you can kind of see it'll get to 100
then you can pick it up right there this
is my footage so let's not judge me too
harshly but you have to survive until
dawn until 5am and i got to like four
whatever it was the last enemy and it
killed me
uh yeah it sucked but there is also the
bedroom tape that comes with the band
footage dlc and this is more of an
escape room based around marguerite the
uh matriarch of the baker family she
essentially you wake up and you're you
were watching me play it it's creepy
margarites nuts but you're
you're handcuffed to the bed
and you are
essentially it's got a cool angle i
don't want to spoil it too much but i do
think it's cool um here jake decker and
john luke did a stream yesterday
so there's a lot of stuff to do in the
room to escape it obviously but also if
she hears something loud she will come
back into the room so the twist is
before she comes back you have to like
reset everything you did or as much as
possible so she doesn't see that you are
out of bed and kill you you have to get
back in bed and like handcuff yourself
again so she doesn't notice
it's pretty creepy it adds like a really
cool tense layer to it sure it's awesome
i really like this escape room um i
think too much of it is kind of that um
the
pitfall that a lot of like
point-and-click adventures fall into
where
after a certain point i wasn't really
solving a puzzle i was just like
scanning the environment inch by inch to
try to find something i could interact
with uh jean-luc didn't have as much
trouble as i did i think maybe i just
had just played nightmare so i wasn't
paying too much attention to the details
but the clc is very good at ten dollars
they have another one confirmed and then
the season pass though is thirty dollars
so in order for that to make sense there
has to be at least like two more dlcs if
they're both gonna be ten dollars
because it's not even a deal if there's
gonna be three that's thirty dollars
that makes sense what i have a couple
questions what uh
i guess without spoiling anything are
you playing as someone that's not ethan
is the the idea being that it's like a
different timeline so it's it's it's the
clancy jarvis timeline if you play the
game he is the cameraman for the um that
show okay so it's essentially if you
play the beginning hour demo there's a
certain point where he gets knocked out
it's pretty much between that and then
between this other thing that happens in
later in resident evil 7 without
spoiling anything so you're clancy
jarvis the cameraman all right um i
think that does that make sense to you
guys as far as you are in the game yeah
okay cool so we don't have to spoil that
but yes you're clancy jarvis
um and then the basement's the same
layout as it is in the game okay um yeah
and you said you can do this in vr
yes it's vr compatible but apparently
ethan must die mode is also included in
this and it's harder than mad house
apparently he can take like no damage at
all i didn't get the chance to play it
but a lot of people they just said
there's a there's a hard as nails quote
unquote ethan must die mode
uh and i didn't get the chance to play
but mad house is already hard as hell
john luke was playing it and
it was just
like jack just warps around different
things having different points items are
in different places and yeah like
enemies are just tougher in general but
it essentially just sounds like ethan
must die is even harder which i don't
know we're going to get our next segment
actually is we're going to get into like
games that are better on their hardest
difficulty um
i don't think resident evil 7 is but
there are games but ethos die kind of
sounds like maybe a third play through
difficulty you want to get into that
it's kind of interesting how like
i mean how i'm seeing it just because
this dlc is kind of different right like
it's like meant for replayability i
wonder if they'll do something
uh
as different for the next one or will it
be like another type of like survival
thing i don't know right because the
yeah it's a cool blend right it's just a
new mode which is good enough that could
have been an update but then there's the
escape room which is more puzzle based
and kind of this tension but then
there's the nightmare which is more
combat oriented and survival focused
i like nightmare a lot i actually want
to play keep playing i did like four
run-throughs and like the closest i got
was my first one um so you have to pick
between the shotgun uh you don't have to
pick between these things but obviously
you have to know how to spend your money
it's one of those things where you i'm
sure people will start to get into a
routine you can set up these traps like
turrets right here you can kind of see
on the wall behind him uh these wire
traps that destroy them
right there but yeah you start opening
up more of the basement and getting
other scrap benches there's two scrap
benches at least that i found i think
that's all there is that you can
actually build them but that lock door
right there there's another compactor
behind it
it it was fun i actually really liked it
and for different reasons and i like the
main game there are a lot of enemies in
nightmare compared to the main game uh
but i really do like it i think it's
worth the 10 if you haven't uh if you've
beaten resident seven it did come out i
think
i like the idea that they're trying to
be you know the for honor release coming
up on valentine's day there's horizon on
the 28th two weeks after rather you know
like they're not competing with anything
at the moment really i mean you got neo
next week which is if you don't know
it's like the japanese myth oriented uh
kind of dark souls-ish game and i'm not
just comparing it to dark souls like we
compare everything to dark souls bits
it's like actually like dark souls yeah
oh yeah miguel concepcion is playing
through that apparently it's pretty
tough um but his review will be up
that's like a very tomorrow i believe in
progress very different style of game
obviously so it's yeah again the
competition yeah so if you are
interested in neo then uh that review
will be up tomorrow morning but we do
have a lot of resume 7 footage up but i
just want to get into questions about
the band footage um
i don't know if you guys had any other
things you're curious about uh not a
whole lot do you think
you think you'll play in your basement
kylie
uh yeah my room's in the basement i'm
really paranoid that people are going to
look at me through the window because
it's like ground level so maybe not yeah
but the psvr is in the living room so i
might just do that instead and use that
as my excuse like oh i want to play it
in vr
yeah
there's something about those scenes
where you
i mean i i guess i don't want to spoil
it but she like well
she she's like you know you're pretty
gross like yeah imagine that in vr like
you're locked up and you're being
force-fed
body parts i was i was gonna bring that
up when i played i did a couple of the
demos in vr and when they're like
force-feeding you it's horrible like i
physically i moved out of range i think
like i moved so far back that it didn't
work anymore and i had to like
recalibrate
it was not good did not enjoy that yeah
i mean i did and i didn't because it was
like cool and gross
but her face is horrible what do you
guys think of the game overall so far
i like it all i think you and i talked
about this about the not
like sort of not thematically but there
you feel the uh classic resident evil
um kind of spirit flowing through it we
talked about that a little bit um and
that's what i like about it i like that
there's
some of that um i like that it's
actually scary like terrified
could you play it i agree sorry one more
quick before this phase from the chat
this is gonna make no sense if you're
watching this breakout on youtube but
eric green said rob is central perk from
france he's where everyone wants to be
or maybe all his friends want to crawl
inside him rob you're hating this so
much and that's why i'm enjoying it so
much great uh yeah
it's all good a friend's joke from
earlier in the show yeah let's talk
about video but anyway yeah touching
back
uh
thank you eric i find uh
the the jump scares to be
not cheap right like
there's one in the beginning uh
where you know it's
it got me so good and i'm actually a
pretty big scaredy cat and i will yell
and it was like 1 2 a.m my roommate was
like dude will you shut up because i'm
just it's not just like a yell it's like
a sentence i'm yelling
uh like it's you know it's they're well
done in the respect that like
they come at you when you're the most
vulnerable or
are
how are you feeling is the most
surprising like i think i was telling
one of you guys like you
they got me so good when i had just done
something like it was leading up to like
an accomplishment and i was like oh
great like i'm doing pretty good in this
game and right as you're hitting that
feeling
jump scare and that's when it got me so
good i was just screaming uh
and that's fun i like i have like a
weird like i want to say relationship
with like horror movies i just don't
know like
sometimes it's just i hate the ones
where it's like i'm just up all night
thinking about
said movie yeah i can't go to sleep
someone being in your room about to kill
you right yeah i think i was scared of
the ring for like 10 straight years
totally and then i watched it again i
was like what why was i scared of that i
do oh sorry oh no i was gonna say the
exorcist is my uh the movie that has
haunted me forever wait really watch it
again yep it's one of my favorite movies
and i can't watch it anymore i can't
handle chucky like the doll
i don't know why i just can't and they
made a bishop figure of chucky like it's
a little it's horrible i hate it
anyway i meant to ask you mike because
i've been curious about this you are
easily startled
i would say i think everyone could agree
on that yes how do and you really like
horror and i'm really curious
how that works uh
it's more
i don't know it's kind of masochistic i
guess but also
i don't i don't know i i don't i don't
have anything against jump scares
there's like adrenaline high somewhere
in there like maybe it is sort of like i
i appreciate horror more when it's more
dread and tension and disturbing than
jump scares yeah right right i like
resident seven or that's why i used to
like resident evil 7 or resident evil 3
nemesis because it's the thing hunting
you the whole time the nemesis and then
i replayed it with mary kish recently
and i don't like that game anymore like
i think it's bad ish
i think it's an okay game that's a
separate conversation but we uh i'm
gonna plug it quick and mary kish and i
play through all the resident evil games
on uh resident knievel but uh there's a
lot of resident evil content we have up
but uh i don't know maybe it is like a
masochistic or the adrenaline rush of
horror um i appreciate like good horror
movies that actually
like i said increase the dread like it
follows one of my favorite horror movies
i love it follows yes and i like the
idea that it's not don't you don't do
there are a couple jump scares but it's
but it's they're earned really like the
night the beach i won't be saying
anymore the beach is pretty or the the
bedroom door if that makes sense yes
it's good but
uh yeah i don't know i don't i i don't
scare too easily in terms of like i jump
scary easily but i don't scare too
easily in terms of actually getting
creeped out or nothing
gore doesn't bother me were you scared a
lot in this game like were you jumping
around seven yeah um
yes uh there were a couple times being
chased in this game which is something i
think outlast and from what i played
about last two they do really well is
the terror of being chased knowing
someone's right behind you especially
because jack baker in this game oh
yeah um
there's there's someone that chases you
in the dlc that's
it's way faster than you are so it's
terrifying because you can outrun it you
never know that so that's why vr i think
works really well with this game because
it feels like they're right behind you
not just you know right behind ethan the
character or anything um and yeah like
zero hx c07 was saying psychological
horror is the best horror i totally
agree the stuff that actually can mess
with you mentally is my favorite
did you watch the whaling no um it was a
2016 korean horror film that one was
super psychological and it's like two
and a half hours or something and i just
thought about it for the next two days
oh yeah that's one i would recommend
eric green again the one who compared
you to central perk i believe he was
saying green room had some body horror
that stuck me a few days green room's
really good that's more that's less like
horror but it's more uh like gore and
like super kind of realistic looking
violence but
anyway
resident evil 7 uh i completely
recommend this dlc if you've beaten it
or if you like keep it in your mind
while you're beating resident evil 7 uh
it's got a lot of good variety we might
be doing more extensive write-up i'm not
completely sure i think scott
butterworth wants to check it out at
some point see what he wants to do and
pete brown our reviews editor will be
the one to make that call but we have a
lot of resident evil 7 content up right
now we have reviving resident evil our
uk team
and myself traveled to japan at capcom
semi recently a couple months ago to uh
do a behind the scenes documentary about
resident evil 7
and also how it influenced like indie
horror and how indie horror influenced
uh this the newest game and how the
series kind of declined until now um we
do have another thing that you jake and
i are working on kind of semi-soonish
about resident evil 7 and silent hills
and whatnot so yeah just go over to
gamespot we have a lot of good resume
seven content up and uh we read the
comments so leave your thoughts and we
will respond to them when we get the
chance
all right
that's actually a really good segue
uh we wanted to do an evergreen feature
kind of about games that are better on
their hardest difficulties
and by that we can be pretty flexible
maybe like they're they're an alternate
difficulty like a survival mode rob
you've done a couple videos last year
about this um for a couple different
games so i'll let you start it off but
essentially just games that you can
enjoy more when
they're at their hardest
yeah it's it's really interesting too
because
dating back to the fallout for survival
mode
[Music]
sometimes a game i feel like uh for
example fallout where you know later in
the game
you become so overpowered and i think
you hear that even maybe with dishonored
i think scott uh
had the same sentiment where like
when the game just gets almost boring
where you feel like so overpowered like
that's kind of like a solution is to
have a survival mode or play the game
differently with like no powers right
for dishonored uh fallout 4 was one of
those games where it was like i have 130
stims
uh at the ready there is never going to
be a moment where i'm power armor yeah
power companion i'm just plowing through
this game i don't feel like a survivor
anymore which i think the early stages
of the game do really well right and
that's so
fallout right so you kind of lose that
uh
and that's why survival mode was so cool
was it just
in so many areas just limited like how
much you could take with you so instead
of you know adding weight to stims means
i can't take 130 i can only take like
maybe five also when i
when i use them they
are not immediate they don't replenish
my health immediately so it's like a
slow burn yeah so when you're in combat
they're not get out of jail free cards
they're not really just
a resort when you have to get out of a
fight or at least just gradually while
you're getting wounded still there were
so many things in that in that mode that
like really like just made the game so
much better and made everything seem so
dire like being in a fight and uh having
you know the only way you can save the
game is by sleeping in a bed so it's
like crap
i haven't saved i mean it's pretty
brutal but it's like i haven't saved in
an hour i'm in this fight i'm about to
die
your heart just like picks up and you
know we talked about adrenaline high
like that's
it was cool to like have that again uh
and you know as far as last year goes so
many games were doing that you know what
i mean it felt like every other month
was like oh far cry has a survival mode
oh you know division now has a survival
mode which i haven't played yet division
that one sounds pretty fun actually yeah
um uh it's a totally different
game yeah that's hyperbolic it's very
very different it it's the same game map
did you play it kelly mm-hmm you uh did
you play to the division no no i barely
did either but from what i played i
played more survival than i did the base
game because i like it that much more uh
it's yeah you're fighting to get to the
center it actually feels i think it's
kind of along what you're saying with
fallout 4 the boston wasteland it feels
like it fits more in the world this
post-apocalyptic new york city you know
uh winter like virus
this virus-induced winter um and
actually yeah right now another example
that i didn't write down i want to get
to jacob decker is a big fan of the last
of us as a lot of people are um but
someone else uh
hans l hans nell forgive me if i miss
pronouncing that in the youtube chat
said last of us grounded mode and i
totally agree for the same haven't even
heard of that oh yeah for the same
reason it's uh it's just it's much
harder like in terms of how much it's
more realistic in terms of how much
damage joel can take before he dies or
at least gets wounded um crafting
they're much sparser items uh you have
to manage their supplies much more
fastidiously i i love the resource
management aspect right
grounded mode makes it better because
you're worrying so much more in the long
run like
because i re replaying the game you're
like okay [ __ ] i have this stuff coming
up in pittsburgh or i know in iowa this
is going to go down and i want like
enough items for this to be uh
manageable and it fits within the world
right again it's a post-apocalyptic
world where you're just coming across
these household items that you're
fashioning into shivs or you know ammo
yeah and i like that it make it forces
you to
um pay more attention because
i mean if you're replaying the game for
you know a third or fourth time because
i love last of us like i always feel
like playing it um it you know what's
coming up and it makes a lot more sense
to
have to plan far ahead i feel like i do
that in games anyway like a lot of games
where i'm like oh i won't use this
potion because what if i need it in five
hours and then i never use it um whereas
on grounded you do end up using
everything you have because you have so
little and i think that makes the
experience a lot better right for sure
and like same with the division same
with fallout 4 it kind of just feels
more at home within the world they build
same with even resident evil right like
the amount of bullets you have like five
bullets
that's all you got yeah
four on harder difficulties despite how
action oriented that game is
the item management is
much more enticing on harder difficulty
i think and trying to manage it right
and even things like titanfall we've
talked about where uh
i played that on normal
i mean off the bat like that game was
just way too easy uh on its normal mode
but you put on master
you are approaching like these areas you
know like you know that in that game
there's like those when those ticks
yeah uh i forgot that's like the second
or third map where these ticks are just
coming out kind of thing you're just
constantly running and uh
you you
you know that game is very much not a
cover based shooter it's a wall-running
shooter this mo and this mode is
different than the other games we're
talking about in that it encourages you
to play the game in a very different way
than you might other shooters and i
would argue like in the way that it
should be played which is like keep
moving the game is even you know the
game
is trying to reinforce the idea that
like you know it says it even though as
a death screen like keep moving uh and
that's how you play multiplayer so
having that like having played like half
of that game on master i still want to
beat it uh
kind of just clicked for me was like i
just got to keep moving like right which
was something that i didn't have to do
in the normal uh normal mode of the game
so um yeah it's
it's you know just looking at a
different approach of like making a game
harder like can strengthen or reinforce
its like core mechanics or like how the
game is meant to be played
um and i found that interesting yeah you
did videos on both titanfall 2 and
fallout 4 survival mode both of which
were saying kind of these are the this
is the way this game should be played do
you think these games would both be
better on these difficulties for the
first playthrough
or just something you should try once
you like beat it
all right for for titanfall i would say
uh and then i mean i guess both of these
i would recommend like later unless
you're like
really great at shooters or
whatnot with titanfall uh i would
recommend that you know at least like at
the second hardest mode uh fallout was
if like i can't i could not imagine
playing that game off the bat like in
the beginning
with survival mode like you it's so
brutal like already it's like you have
nothing yeah no stims nothing and you
just step outside like i feel like a rad
roach would just like bite your head off
and be like well [ __ ] this yeah yeah for
sure um i do want to call it a couple um
before we get to cali if you had any you
wanted to mention i i had one that's
sort of cheating if i can't do it um i
really want to shout out undertale's
genocide run
um if you aren't familiar with undertale
there are several there i think there's
like seven or so endings um but if you
play through
a first place through and just play
normally um you get like a pretty normal
ending and if you play genocide where
you kill literally everything in the
game um there's this phenomenal final
boss that it took me two weeks to beat i
played every night for two weeks jesus
to memorize
the combat in undertale's like sort of
bullet hell so um i played every night i
would come home from work and play
uh and i finally beat it it was like the
most satisfying thing i've ever done and
it uh the mode itself i mean it's not
technically a mode it's just like you
can choose to play the game that way
which is why this is cheating a little
bit but um
uh i think
it really enhances the point of that
mode which is uh
undertale is a lot about personhood and
agency um and that's a lot of what the
game's about and it really drives that
home really well especially if you play
this a second time so this is another
one i think you wouldn't want to play it
for the first time doing that um but i
would recommend like if you've already
beaten undertale playing through it
again killing literally everything
that's super coincidental and fortunate
i actually just finally got undertale on
steam so maybe i'll check that out if
like if i like the game enough to do a
second play through maybe i'll try that
out um i did want to talk about somewhat
so zero again sorry for butchering this
but zero
hx c07 mentioned metro 2033's ranger
mode uh metro last light has a similar
difficulty which that's very much a
similar vein as the games we were
talking about in terms of the survival
being
a lot
more intense and you have to be a lot
more
careful fastidious with your items i
love metro last light i like 2033 but
like after playing last light uh 2033
kind of piles in comparison i want to
talk about far cry primal uh they
brought out a survival mode as well uh
and you know how kind of when the sun
goes down in that game that's when the
predators come out and you want to have
a fire or at least like a torch to kind
of ward wolves away but this is very
much the same thing you don't have as
much of an interface so it feels more
like you're just kind of in this world
the cold is much more damaging to you
once you go to the northern sections of
the game i think this game was a little
bit forgettable because it was sort of
along the far cry 34 it was it was a far
cry 34 clone just in the stone age
but i think they actually made good use
of it especially with the survival mode
it was much harder to it felt it felt
just as brutal as the story was trying
to tell you the game was as opposed to
the first play through which i still
really liked actually but i
i actually might recommend playing this
game for the first time in the survival
mode because if especially if you played
far cry 3 and 4 and looking for
something truly different to feel like
this caveman surviving in this dangerous
world where like the animals in the
environment are more almost more of a
threat to you than the humans are i
think you sh people if you have not
played far cry primal yet which you know
it didn't really get a lot of game to
work game of the year or anything or any
accolades or awards but i think it is an
underrated game and i think people
should play it in survival mode did the
in that mode that sounds interesting
like the whole knight aspect because
that was something about that game where
uh it seemed missed because again
if i remember correctly you could just
warp back to a campfire and sleep out
the night yeah did they remove that if
they remove that that'd be cool i
believe fast travel is not in survival
mode that's cool right then you're like
see you see the sun going right that
would be that's that's you're totally
right they did remove i remember that
that needed to happen that is because
then you're like you hear a saber tooth
kind of like howling right right howling
what do they do screeching
sure roaring
meow there's a saber tooth swooping down
to grab you right um and
yes i actually would tell people to play
this is one of those few games i would
say play this on the hardest difficulty
first because i think you'll appreciate
this game more uh it sets itself apart
from far cry 3 and far cry 4 a little
more um last one i wanted to mention
xcom 2's iron man and x-com enemy
unknowns iron man mode uh this is the
perma-death mode i
don't think you're playing x-com the
right way if you don't have permadeath
enabled if you want to reload a save and
try to redo something i don't think
you're getting the full impact of that
game xcom 2 was one of my favorite games
last year i've never played next time
game i played an xcom one playthrough
out of my
60 playthroughs of xcon games not with
permadeath and i think that's because
you don't feel the impact of losing
someone just much like fire emblem uh
you won't feel the impact of that unless
you're actually losing these people for
good you start getting attached to these
snipers not because like their character
models or their
their dialogue cheesy dialogue but
because you're like oh [ __ ] i just lost
my my brazilian sniper who
had like 65 confirmed kills her weapon
was outfitted really well i lost that i
lost all her good armor like you
actually feel it and then you there's a
genuine like disappointment and like
regret
knowing like if i just thrown this
flashbang at this point or killed this
mutant before this happened it like
crushes you that's really smart like
that's a really good pick i would
actually say
xcom
x same thing xcom should be played on
ironman i don't think you're playing
xcom if you're not on ironman mode that
reminds me fire emblem on classic mode
yeah you're not playing fire emblem if
you're if you you can't lose your
potential husband and then cry
i don't think that counts i've been
waiting to get into firearm games uh i
played awakening a little bit but i
sadly i did not get more into it but uh
are you more a fan of fates or we talked
about this before we talked about it
yeah i think so but yeah i broken record
i guess but um
sorry monroe when i said real life has
permadeath i play games for the escape
that's a valid concern that's true yeah
i mean maybe if you're new to fire
emblem i would say play it on
the not permadeath yeah but the thing is
i'm the kind of person i always reset a
game if something i don't like happens
um and so my challenge to myself is not
to do that yeah but it's the same thing
where it's like oh i lost this person
that had these skills that i really
needed like now i have to go on and
figure out how to
go on without that sure or my wife who
died no
yeah yeah it's because fire emblem once
you get a little farther in the game the
meta becomes more about like building
relationships and what not right yeah
okay yeah well and then you like it's
sort of weird we have to kind of breed
people
for better
children who can be soldiers genetic
engineering i mean cool sure but i i do
think a lot of people care about the
relationship aspect and fire emblem so
that does have that emotional effect
in addition to the disappointment of
like oh i lost my best healer or
whatever it is right right um
yeah i i cause you could play like x
com2 on easy but still have iron man
mode enabled or rookie and still have
iron man 2. so the actual enemies will
be a little easier but you still lose
people so i think even if you're playing
for the first time go on rookie but set
iron man mode i couldn't be mistaken
about this but i think e like rookie has
iron man mode either way i'm just like
talking about x-com too but i'm gonna
shut up now uh yeah so those are the
ones we wanted to mention but if anybody
watching right now wants to throw a few
more in the chat we've seen like the
last of us metro 2033 both great picks
uh leave your thought in the comments
and we'll peruse them and try to get
back to you thanks
all right this seems to be what a lot of
people are here for horizon zero dawn
uh not too far away like no
four weeks almost exactly yeah just went
gold yeah two so it's ready to release
from a gorilla games of killzone fame uh
but really big shift for them yeah
obviously it's third person open world
action with rpg elements very different
yeah and kelly you went you recently
went down to a preview event at in los
angeles yes and you got to play more so
we played at e3 scott butterworth i
believe and jake decker both played a
few preview events and they got like
smaller chunks of the open world to
explore yeah from my understanding it
wasn't it was more combat focused like
oh dropping you into a combat situation
whereas i got to play
what i presume was the beginning of the
game i think for the first hour and a
half and then for another
two and a half hours i played just kind
of explored and
crafted and looked at the skill tree a
whole bunch and and did a lot of combat
and climbed a giant machine so you have
a preview up on gamespot which if uh
after the show you guys can all go read
for more in-depth uh preview
as the game is approaching release uh
kelly wrote it it's very good i read
through it and i'm really excited for
the game now i try i've actually this is
one of those games i've been you know
it's one of the things if i didn't work
at game spot i would try to
watch preview footage much less just so
i'm actually i don't know a ton about
the games when they come out but yeah by
the nature of our job we kind of have to
this is one of the games i was trying to
avoid but obviously for the segment
today and whatnot i read up more on it
after you had written your preview and
i'm excited for it um i think my
questions mainly revolve around the
gameplay loop how it works in general
the structure of it because we've seen
they released that cinematic trailer
recently yeah we're watching right now
kind of shows more the game's very story
oriented um we can go into the premise
of it soon but i guess we could just
kind of do a general roundabout of how
the game works because i think there's a
lot of people are talking about you said
like e3 they showed off the combat and
whatnot yeah that's my understanding i
didn't get to play at e3 but um yeah
i've been excited about this game ever
since i saw it i feel like i have the
exact same hair she does so i got really
good reminds me of um
uh starts with an n the protagonist's
name from heavenly sword
um
i'll i'll look it up
but um uh yeah basically uh i was trying
to figure out what like a typical
gameplay loop would look like um and
it's a lot of
hunting down the machines for parts so
one of the early missions is like
literally to just get some parts so you
can get fire arrows to go on a like a to
attack a bigger machine okay um and so
there's a lot of that i found it really
satisfying because um the weaponry is
obviously very like ancient inspired
there's bow and arrow spears and stuff
like that um but being able to
effectively kill a machine
doesn't seem as weird and contradictory
as it
initially is like it sounds like okay
well how's an arrow gonna do any damage
to like a metal
saber-toothed tiger thing
yeah it just doesn't make any sense um
but there she has like a scanning device
and it looks like sort of like a
bluetooth wearable and
google glass you get to yeah you get to
uh
oh hi somebody says hi in the chat um
you get to play as her as a like a
six-year-old for a very brief amount of
time and that's when she finds it um and
you can scan the area you can track um
sort of where a machine is if they have
like a set path and then one of the
things you can do is highlight their
weak points um and that makes the arrow
strike oh and it's a freaking trophy
notifications were on when i was
capturing um
and i so it felt more natural than i
thought it would be i guess it's what
i'm saying so i found that really
satisfying um the
variety in machines we got to see a
little bit more initially there's like
the watchers which we'll call more to
you um so the
main strategy there is to just take out
the watchers first um and then there's
kind of this big
i don't i think it's a sawtooth or
something like that um damn like instead
of a saber tooth they just have saws for
teeth i mean sure i didn't get a good
look at its teeth because i was running
away from it okay so here's here's my
thing and this is not a negative comment
but
i think a lot of people are comparing it
to far cry in third person you know the
hunting gathering yeah open world
stealth or action and then three skill
tree did it feel like far cry games to
you yeah i would i would say that's a
fair comparison modern far cry games i
guess two and honestly even this right
here yeah outpost you take over for sure
and i think what you you send in or you
take it over and your tribe will then
spawn there or live there right or
something like that which is far cry
primal yeah right um yeah that was just
like we were investing i think i had to
investigate uh
some somebody there was like a massacre
and i was investigating it um this is
where i got to climb a giant machine
that was really cool um yeah so it i
think that's a fair comparison i do
think that the
the one of the big uh drivers for me to
keep playing is figuring out why the
world is the way it is because obviously
it's far future i think it's a thousand
years in the future
post-post-apocalyptic
and i'm really curious to see like what
the deal with that is and i feel like
there were a lot of hints in the demo i
played uh toward what that would be but
i didn't get a lot of information um so
i think that's the main
like if you're wondering like oh why
should i play this if i you know
i hope it's good already yeah i hope
it's like oh damn
i know i hope yeah so here's why
i hope this isn't spoiling anything i
don't think it is but all right there's
a short story from back in the day uh
july 31 1937 by steven vincent binet um
i
it's naruko nariko by the way from
heavenly sword thank you a few people
said it bones nelson said that um anyway
by the waters of babylon if you get the
chance to read it if you're excited for
horizon read it it's a short story you
could find like a pdf if you search by
the waters of babylon the first thing
that comes up on google is the pdf
it is i don't wanna now i don't wanna
spoil the short story it's
it's horizon zero dawn remember last
time we did this in the lobby and i said
i think they got watchdog two from
bedazzled
oh god damn it and then we found out
holy [ __ ] as well set in san francisco
much like watchdogs too there yeah okay
by the waters of babylon is a story
about you've heard it here first yes
it's a story about these people in this
tribal society that go to these places
to find metal it's
it's the currency and then you start to
find out there's a huge twist to it uh
you can read the short story
now the twist isn't as novel but i
remember reading this short story like
seventh grade and be like holy [ __ ]
and it sounds a lot like horizon and i
have my suspicion that they might be
going this route but uh check it out by
the waters of babylon by stephen vincent
bonnet
i would just want it not to be
we made the machines and the machines
took over
like i don't want the terminator i like
that you have to do the accent like that
because like i'm right there with you
like that it came with an accent yeah
because a lot of times i'm talk today
it's like the
it's the beginning of the movie
yeah or i mean like my initial before i
thought start thinking about this short
story
was
maybe like a nuclear war happened and
then like tribal warfare
sprouted back up sure but
would you even need
nukes in a thousand years when you have
these robots
but the robots seem they're like
autonomous right they're they're wild
animals
well no you can override them
um and use one type of them as a mount
and then the watchers don't seem like
the other ones seem to be
like beholden to the watchers okay so
but i can't say for certain okay oh i
think there's something going on there i
don't know
so in terms of the ones that look like
brontosaurus with like starship
enterprises on their head that you i
think rob you describe them as that so
are those like a map they are unlocking
parts of the map yeah you climb up and
it's like radar like radio towers yeah
exactly okay and again i'm not i'm not
downplaying this because it seems like
fallout it's a lot of other games have
uh kind of mimicked fallout 3's or
fallout 2's open world structure it's
that cascading structure of opening the
map getting more quests which lead to
other quests which leads to items which
leads to hunting which leads to skills
which leads back to the rest yeah i i
don't mind that but i would love if this
game felt really unique
uh
as of now i just could see it feeling
like a far cry game but yeah i mean you
played it i have not i'm really excited
for it i'm really looking forward to
playing more yeah um
for the combat you you had your opinions
about the combat too how it fit into the
world it feels like
it feels good yeah you can read all
about that on gamespot.com yeah um and
also there's uh more gameplay that you
can check out and we have 4k gameplay as
well um because this game does look
really good yeah gorilla always kind of
nails it on the head with the visuals
yeah i think the only thing was the
camera was a little wonky for me okay um
but like at some points um but yeah so
the combat uh like i said like the
weapons don't feel ineffective but you
also don't feel overpowered and i like
the skill how the skill tree feeds into
combat um and kind of shapes
how i played i focused more on stealth
while i was there so i'm excited to try
different
routes and everything like that um i'm
just really looking forward to playing
more i didn't really want to leave i had
to catch a flight this was a day trip
how long did you play we do have
questions four and a half hours okay
cool um i'm gonna throw some questions
at you and you might a lot of these you
might not even know or any of us might
know but i'll i'll uh i'll pick ones
that you might so did you get a sense of
the scope of the map because adam roston
on twitter had said
how does corizon how does horizon
compare to other open worlds as far as
scope and scale i mean it's always hard
to compare games like you know grand
theft auto 5 to the witcher but right
did this feel big um i i can't really
tell uh there was a lot of fog of war
kind of stuff on the map um so the
climbing up on that uh i think it's
called a long neck or something not on
long tall next tall neck i was like
that's that is the land before time yeah
um
oh yeah wait was was it
petri was the main character i don't
know that's the bat i don't want to
think about it it makes me cry i'm the
main character
um
bigfoot little fit petri
shut up what you brought it you
shouldn't even
um
central perk over here
that that cleared a little bit of the
fog of war but i can't i could not tell
from what i played um
how how big and expensive it was okay
cool i saw some cool in the comments i
don't know if you can uh confirm this
cali you can the robots drink oil from
the ground
there's one thing like that they're like
they're called grazers and they were
always digging in the ground but i
didn't actually pay attention to what
they were doing because i was trying to
kill them
so
sure they might be i don't know if oil
was that plentiful do you think they
would really have that big of a problem
with their society
probably well maybe like drinkable water
becomes the big thing yeah um so amazing
786 said how meaningful and deep does
the side content feel are we talking
witcher 3 level a lot of which are three
comparisons because that kind of nailed
the open world formula or average
average ubisoft title
i would say
it's certainly not at a witcher 3 level
from what i can tell obviously this
game's not out so i don't want to like
say definitively um but there were like
i went on side quests and it like one of
them was to help a lady find her missing
brother who had been cast out because
he
attacked somebody or something it was
like this whole backstory and she talked
for like a million years and um so it
seems like it it's a lot of world
building in side quests from from what i
saw i mean there were other kind of not
fetch questy things but it was like oh
find some meat for this lady and i'm
like i'm not doing that so
i'm not going to get she can find her
own meat so that's right because there i
i didn't even like realize that there
are like rabbits and
animals running around as well yeah you
can hunt organic matter and you can kill
people
no you're not eating metal you're not
eating no nobody eats metal glass like
the grinch
um
jacob white on twitter he's asking if
there's an upgrade system for like your
mounts dinosaur butts did you get a
sense of that or just pretty much
standard like um i was i treated my my
mounts as disposable i would
override it i would right amount where i
wouldn't want it to go and then i used
it as bait
and another machine would attack it so i
did not get that far
i was like eh you can just fight this
machine for me i'm gonna go gather
things a lot of people are asking if
there's gonna be a demo from this for
this game uh michael cartoriel had asked
i don't think so i think this game's out
and it just went gold it's in three
four weeks yeah games almost think so so
sadly we have to wait
one thing that sucks this game is out
three days before the twit or five four
days before
four days before the switch nintendo
switch
four days before zelda like obviously i
don't think they knew
that
before nintendo announced the release
date of march 3rd this game's out
february 28th yeah i mean i don't even
have try to beat this game in three days
before you get a nintendo switch if you
plan on it yeah
i am really torn because i've been
wanting to play zelda for so long
but i really did enjoy
playing horizon and i want to play more
so it's gonna be a weird balancing act
between two open world games that are
very different because i don't think
horizon doesn't seem like it's directly
competing with
if you're like super nintendo games but
if you're like saving up money for a
switch
then it might be tough to do both of
those in one week especially the time
like between zelda's own world like you
just said it and horizon horizon's gonna
it's not a short game doesn't look like
it no it does not look short ugh
all right it's unfortunate but at least
we'll have both at least
neither
yeah um
and then i think that was all the
questions i wanted to bring up all right
cool so
yeah that was our last segment on
horizon zero dawn that released february
28th for uh playstation 4. cali has a
preview up
on game spot now you can go read that we
also have a few discussions from e3 last
year kind of outdated but it still might
be relevant uh the cinematic trial is up
on game spot you can watch that get a
sense of the story of the game let us
know what you think in the comments
and that is our show
a little shorter than last week a little
shorter than uh that injustice 2 segment
went really well yeah super well got got
friends up on there though yeah yeah
proud of you central perk over here pete
is the ross
disappointed we didn't see more of those
but uh what are you guys playing are you
you're still playing titanfall 2 aren't
you
uh i'm gonna do my best to finish
resident evil uh yeah i'm gonna try to
play it
i don't know i got so scared last time
but uh speaking of which
speaking of again if you weren't if you
weren't here at the beginning of the
show uh if you go on follow follow and
reply to gamespot's twitter account in
which we tweeted saying this later in
the week we'll pick a winner um so for
some reason there is like a
steelbook case it looks like but
the game is not our sample this is like
a sample that they sent us this does not
include the game so we took the liberty
of putting an xbox one copy to include
with this so if you have an xbox one and
want this
um
yeah it's got the uh a
mansion music box eight inches tall
plays a sample of the ant roadie
soundtrack dummy finger 4g usb drive
drive yes finger drive vhs
vhs tape box uh there's a lithograph a
creepy note
and
premium packaging i get creepy notes all
the time i know you can get those for
free so uh later in the week we'll pick
a winner from our random winner from our
twitter replies so follow gamespot and
reply to that tweet which is up now
all right
that's our show callie what are you
playing uh soon this is heavy uh
resident evil yeah for sure gotcha cool
all right
uh thanks to everyone in back uh eric
tay richard lee jean-luc psyche we are
uh
fully functioning crew people been out
sick kind of last week in the week
before it's been cold in san francisco
yeah i've been really cold you're still
sick i'm probably gonna be sick now i
did a couple shots of dayquil yeah it's
nice you know what else helps what
nyquil at night
not coming to work and getting us all
sick you're a tough crowd i just i i'm
sorry
uh i just have a little congestion
that's all um
but also if you want to plug uh we're
doing a stream later
yeah so four o'clock pacific uh rob i
was gonna be on i don't think i am
anymore i don't know uh we have uh call
of duty devs and coming in to play the
new zombies uh the redwood dlc
yes so uh they'll be playing that live
stream for about an hour hour and a half
uh we'll have like four players uh with
a call of duty dev so that will be uh
that should be cool on twitch and
youtube
and gamespot later on at 4pm pacific
uh we also we might be streaming
resilience seven no we were streaming
resume seven dlc yesterday but that's
archives you can go watch that the uh
banned footage jean-luc and jake did
that um
kelly's horizon preview is up now uh you
can still go and watch
pretty much
everything for like our resident evil 7
covers again i plug it a ton but
reviving resident evil our game spot
documentary series that tamora and adam
in the uk did it's very good uh yeah and
uh stay tuned to game spot we'll have
more news coming up next week our neo
review progress will be up tomorrow
miguel concepcion who's uh for those who
don't know he's been a freelancer for a
while but he's been a full-time editor
here at gamespot for a couple weeks now
which we're really glad to have him
he'll be on the lobby next week talk
about neo um but yeah keep an eye out
for that review and progress tomorrow
and as always thanks for joining us
we'll see you next week
you